hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about the ras map kinase pathway
the map kinase pathway
is initiated at the receptor level
the receptors which are responsible for
the signal transduction are cell surface
receptor known as receptor tyrosine
kinase
because they have an intrinsic tyrosine
kinase activity
the ligands for these receptors are
mitogens
or the growth factors
upon ligand binding the receptor
tyrosine kinase dimerize
this dimerized receptor is now active
and it phosphorylates
the tyrosine residues in the cytoplasmic
domain
now to this phosphorylated tyrosine
residue specific adductor proteins can
dock such as grb2
grb2 protein has sh2 domain which
recognize phosphotyrosine residues
now grp2 can further interact with
sos protein
sos protein otherwise named as sun of 7
less which was found in drosophila
is actually a guanosine nucleotide
exchange factor
and it helps in gtp exchange
sos actually helps
ras which is a monomeric g protein
to exchange its gdp and replace it with
gtp and thereby activating the ras
protein
if you are wondering that why these
proteins have weird names like sos grb2
then you should watch the video in i
button it talks about the discovery of
sos and the ras mapkin is signaling
pathway
however
let's focus on this pathway for a while
rest
once activated now can
dissociate and move in the membrane to
interact with other kinases such as raf
raf gets activated upon interaction with
rash
and in this moment we should understand
that the activation of rash is not for a
infinite time there are molecules like
gap or gtbs activator protein which can
hydrolyze
the gtp
and render the rash into an inactive
state
when ras is not bound to gtp
raph is no more interacting with ras and
the pathway would be eventually shut
down
anyway when rash is active
raf is also active and it interacts with
another downstream kind is known as mech
and it phosphorylates make
thus activating the make
make further activates and
phosphorylates arc
art is another kinase which then
translocates into the nucleus
and
interacts with several transcription
factors and rna polymerase
for and allow gene expression to happen
and this is how the downstream cascade
in wraps map kinase pathway takes place
now let's talk about what are the genes
which are transcribed by these pathway
the genes that are transcribed by ras
map kinase pathway
are responsible for growth and cell
division such as cyclin t1
also genes which are responsible for
survival proliferation such as c meat
bcl2 bcl excel all of the genes are the
target genes for ras map kinase pathway
from this gene expression profile we can
understand rasnap kinase pathway give
rise to growth division and
proliferation
in in terms of
a tissue or a cell
so overall
ras map kinase pathway is very important
for growing tissue or cells that are
undergoing divisions
now let me tell you
a little bit uh details about this
so one of the target gene of ras mapkins
pathway is actually cycling d
once cycling d is produced it interacts
with its cdk partner that is cdk4r6
and cyclin d eventually phosphorylates
prb protein
prb under normal circumstances hold e2f
protein which is an important
transcriptional modulator
and thereby preventing it to perform its
transcriptional activity
but cyclin d phosphorylates prb
and allows the release of e2f e2f now
can freely bind to the specific gene
region and lead to the transcription of
genes responsible for the s cell s phase
of the cell cycle
so overall we understand how cyclin d
production helps in the progression of
cell cycle from g1 to s
and that kind of explains the growth
activity of map kinase pathway now let
me tell you in cancer ras map kinase
pathway
is perturbed
one of the common thing in cancer is the
mutation in ras oncogene
in the mutated ras the gtpa's activator
protein gap
cannot hydrolyze the gtp
as a result rash is constitutively
active regardless the presence of any
mitogen
because it's a mutation in ras
as a result the downstream effectors
such as raf make arc all of them are
active and the
downstream of this pathway genes are
actually
transcribed
this is leading to uncontrolled
proliferation which might lead to cancer
now we understand how ras mapkins
pathway is responsible for cancer
now let me tell you that when we think
about ras map kinase pathway we always
visualize the receptor tyrosine kinase
to be the initiator of this pathway but
this pathway can be initiated by g
protein coupled receptor as well and
that brings us with the essence of
crosstalk between signaling pathways
there are certain proteins known as beta
arresting which modulates
the g protein coupled receptor pathway
can bind to these gpcrs and recruit a
kinase known as src kinase
src kinase can further phosphorylate arc
and we know arc is downstream to map
kinase pathway so obviously art can
translocate into the nucleus and
activate the genes which are responsible
or which are important for this pathway
which are important for growth survival
or proliferation thereby we can
appreciate how different pathways can
crosstalk at different levels
so with that
let me say that if you like to
support my channel do it on patreon if
you're an indian viewer you can support
me on a
gpa or let's say veeam upi app your
small contribution means a lot for me
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and my courses are also in academy which
is india's biggest online learning
platform in order to take my course use
my code api